let's see a wealthy family is sent to a
world where water is almost non-existent
to extract the best valued substance in
the universe so today on cinema recapped
i'll show you dune
the film begins with a young woman who
lives on doom she says that a group of
people called hakan and came there to
steal a substance called the spice and
become richer than the emperor however
these people left then we meet paul the
son of a wealthy family on another
planet called kaladin he has lunch with
his mother named jessica he trains him
in the use of a skill called the voice
which is used to control other people by
giving the mortars she also asks him if
he has continued to have strange dreams
but he denies it later paul studies
about the desert planet iraqus also
called tune then we meet the head of the
family duklito at treats paul's father
that is cider halleck his war chief and
howit his advisor who is also mented
that is a human being his brain works as
advanced as a computer they and the rest
of the attrites receive an informant
from the emperor who warns them that the
emperor demands that they leave that
planet to go to rule in dune the duke
accepts the task sealing the decree with
his ring let me see duncan arrive the
master of the sword of the atreid's
house who is also a good friend of paul
he tells him that in one of his dreams
he saw him tie into but duncan says he
doesn't have to worry about a dream
later paul tries to convince his father
to let him travel with duncan tattoo but
his father replies that he must travel
with the rest of the family and that if
duncan must travel sooner it is due to a
special mission in which he'll establish
friendship with the race of men into and
cult freeman then hull must continue his
training with halak for which he
activates a shield that is carried flush
with the skin although we realize that
there are weapons that can pass through
this shield alec warns him that the race
that ruled before them the haqqani will
not be very happy about the changes and
then we see the haqqani led by a man
named vladimir his nephew rabin who is
furious and a mentive named pider the
leader calmly says that they shouldn't
worry about the emperor decision but
turning to paul his mother wakes him up
one night so he can meet an old teacher
of her who is interested in his strange
dreams his doctor named checks his vital
signs and then paul is taken to the
teacher who gives him a test in which
she must put a hand in a box and if he
takes it out she will kill him with an
instant poison his hand starts to hurt a
lot but then he remembers a lesson from
his mother that if he allows himself to
be carried away by the fear caused by
the pain then he would be like an animal
being carried away by its instincts so
paul endures the pain firmly until the
teacher says that is enough a teacher
and mother discussed the possibility of
paul being some kind of chosen one given
that he has been having prophetic dreams
although the teacher says it is too
early to be sure shortly afterwards we
see the attributes moving to dune where
the locals welcome paul as if he were
their savior since they noticed an
insides of a legendary figure according
to their culture then the attributes
travel in vehicles called orthopters to
their new home where mrs jessica
receives servants from the untamed
freeman race one of them gives her
weapon cult cries which is very valuable
in their culture and gives it to her for
being the mother of the chosen one later
paul continues his lessons on dune when
he suddenly sees a mosquito size weapon
which is being remotely controlled paul
stands still so that the weapon does not
detect him and when the maid opens the
door the gun is directed at her but paul
saves her life and the duke has mad at
his guards for having allowed his son to
fall into such danger meanwhile vladimir
lies to the old woman from before to
whom he promises that although he plans
to kill the duke he will let jessica and
paul live when in fact he plans to
exterminate them all the attributes have
their first meeting during which hawaii
warns them that the hakonen left them a
very deficient equipment for the
extraction of the spice then we see the
return of duncan who gives a full report
on the freeman admitting that they could
be a very effective army as allies at
that moment a freeman appears which
spits on the table but because that is a
sign of respect he says that he does not
want any envoy from the emperor to come
to their land steal their resources and
attack his people as the harkonnen used
to do the duke says that as ruler he
will go anywhere that is necessary for
his interests but he promises that
freeman people will not be harmed then
they meet with a planetologist named
kines who helps them fit into suits that
help recycle all the water that comes
out of their body together they travel
to see how the spice is extracted the
planetologist explains to them that the
greatest danger during this extraction
are giant worms which are attracted by
the movement on the sand the duke
attacks one of these wars so they wore
the extractors to leave however the
vehicle that was to take the extractor
machine fails making it impossible to
save the spice of the people the two
quarters all his vehicles to go to save
the least people however during the
operation paul gets off the amithapter
and he gets dizzy when he touches the
sand so he is almost eaten by the
gigantic word although they help him to
escape in time later he explains to his
mother that when he touched the sand he
had a vision in which she was kissing a
freeman but then she stabbed him he also
tells her that he knows she's pregnant
although her mother doesn't know how he
knew since she hadn't told anyone
meanwhile we see that the hakonen army
appears to be preparing for battle
jessica promises the duke that she will
protect hull with her own life if
necessary and that night we see dr you
betrayed the attributes deactivating the
city's shields and then anesthetizing
the duke the warmaster does his job
raising the men against the approaching
harkonnen attack although they destroyed
their ships before they can mount them
however halek leads his men on foot
while the royal family's residence is
also invaded by the enemy easily killing
off the internal guards meanwhile massau
explains that he betrayed them because
the haqqani took his wife and that he
will take revenge on them by putting a
deadly poison on a false tooth which the
duke must bite in front of the haqqani
leader to kill him we see that rabin
accepts no prisoners will duncan kills
many haqqani soldiers although he could
not find paul in this room he and his
mother were kidnapped by harkonnen
soldiers covering jessica's mouth so
that she does not use the voice while
duncan kills more enemies and manages to
get an amithopter and escape meanwhile
hull tries to use the voice to control
the hakonen soldiers although it does
not work but then it does work causing
them to kill each other while he and his
mother escape going down to the desert
taking a backpack that apparently
someone left there for them when they
get off the amithapter they see the
destruction caused by the haqqanin and
then they set up a tent to hide in the
desert meanwhile dr yu asks his wife to
be released as promised but vladimir omi
kills him the duke then releases the
poison killing everyone in the room
including himself his family becomes
aware of his death due to doctor you
sending them the doosal ring inside the
backpack duncan confronts the
planetologist who knew that the emperor
had sent them there to die well we see
that the leader hakone managed to
survive the poison thanks to his
suspenders with which he flew to the
ceiling then since paul touched the sand
again he has more visions such as one of
a battle he is a part of having blue
eyes like freeman in another one he sees
his name being shouted after having
taken revenge and he accuses his mother
of having turned him into a monster with
prophetic visions although later he lets
himself be consoled by her when they
leave their hiding place they see duncan
who after the death of the previous duke
offers his loyalty to paul he reunites
them with the planetologist explaining
that the emperor also involved his
armies during the attack to support the
harkonnen hull says that with what
happened the other noble houses could
unite against the empire before the same
happens to them although that would
create chaos that would make things
worse paul says they could turn dune
into a paradise but he has seen it
although the planetologist says that
those are just legends later we see how
the hakkhan arrive at that new hideout
where duncan sacrifices himself so that
the others can escape the planetologist
says that there is only one omnithopter
for two people telling them that they
will escape in it by hiding in a sand
store while she will escape on foot
since she is more used to the desert so
the planetologist plants a device to get
the attention of a worm but then she
gets stabbed in the back however she
sacrifices herself by having the warm
eater and her attackers meanwhile paul
and his mother get into the sandstorm to
get rid of their pursuers will paul has
another vision in which the freeman who
spat on the table earlier explains that
he must let himself flow over time for
what paul decides to be carried away by
the storp in order to survive it
vladimir orders his nephew rabbin to
rule tune and start extracting the spice
again and that he should also kill all
the freemen we see the paul and his
mother manage to survive the sandstorm
although they land in a forced way
losing the vehicle so they must run
towards some rocks before a warm finds
them then they put on the suits that
recycle the water and go in search of
the freemen we see that they have to
walk in a special way to fill the worms
although one of them finds them anyway
so they must run again towards some
rocks they manage to arrive at the very
last moment and paul sees the gigantic
creature face to face then someone else
places a device nearby to get the worms
attention giving them a chance to get
deeper into the rocks but they cannot
rest since at that moment they run into
a group of freemans who want to kill
them to steal the water from their
bodies however one of them recognizes
paul saying that he may be the chosen
one and therefore they should not kill
him although the mother can be killed so
they start fighting the leading freeman
named stilber is surprised by jessica's
fighting ability despairs the life of
one freeman so everyone calm down
meanwhile paul meets the young framing
he has been seeing in his visions and
then mother and sons earned of their
weapons so that they can be welcomed
amid the freedom however one of them
says that he does not accept the
decision to let the woman live so he
demands to carry out a tool for her life
which paul will carry out on behalf of
his mother later paul has a vision in
which she loses the tool and dies then
the freeman girl tells him that she does
not believe that he is the chosen one
although she still wants him to die with
dignity so she lends him her cries for
the battle paul begins losing but then
manages to take advantage although he
does not want to kill his enemy for
which he gets angry since according to
his culture in these duels you can only
win or die jessica says that her son has
never killed anyone and being left
without options paul decides to end the
life of his enemy after which the other
freeman take the body of his deceased
partner while touching paul's shoulder
as a sign of approval silga confirms the
paul can be part of them now and
although jessica tries to refuse saying
that they must return to their previous
planet paul says that he has realized
that his destiny is linked to doom we
see that from that moment mother and son
begin to travel alongside the freeman
realizing that they can even travel on
top of the worms paul is happy to
literally travel with the girl of his
dreams although behind his back we see
that his mother is not very happy with
the decision he made the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best sci-fi movies i
hope you have a great day and i'll see
you in the next video bye